I would like to highlight two main
topics of today's discussion the first
one on behalf of the presidency I
informed my colleagues about the state
of play of our work on the multi-annual
financial framework midterm review that
today's discussion was useful in a way
that I did hear from Minister some
important political messages to further
guide our work and we will do our utmost
to reach a political agreement on this
complex and very challenging file by the
end of the of this year a second and
very important issue at today's council
was the preparation for the European
Council later this week you are familiar
with the three topics on its agenda
migration trade and external relations
on migration the main focus will be on
compacts to take stock of progress ahead
of more in-depth assessment which is
playing for December but other aspects
will also be touched upon such as the
border protection implementation of the
eu-turkey agreement and the common
European asylum system on trade we have
ambitious conclusions addressing ongoing
free trade agreement negotiations and
trade offense instruments importantly it
is crucial to confirm a positive message
about the need to have open robust and
credible trade policy over dinner our
leaders will discuss relations with
Russia he had no formal conclusions are
envisaged and there will be also
language on Syria I did also in the text
of the conclusions which will be
followed following the discussions and
conclusions adopted by the foreign
ministers yesterday slovak Prime
Minister Robert pizza will have a
special role here in at the beginning of
the meeting import informing his
colleagues about the progress in
implementing the conclusions of the
Bratislava summit and the implementation
of Bratislava roadmap and here i can say
at this point that progress is being
made and we can mention as a concrete
examples for example the assistance that
was delivered to bulgaria and also our
agreement on the Paris climate agreement